the surface laptop range has been a huge
hit from Microsoft with the surface to
being one of the best sellers of all
laptops across the spectrum in 2019 so
what can we expect from the surface 3
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
Tom H and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about a highly
anticipated Microsoft Surface laptop 3
now Microsoft is expected to announce
this device on the 2nd of October along
with the Microsoft Pro 7 and also
potentially a Microsoft book 3 this one
is a little bit unconfirmed but we're
looking to get a variety of products
come out at this launch so there's a few
things that we've learned up until this
launch point so far about the surface
laptop 3 and a few things that are
fantastic news for anybody that's
looking to purchase a brand new surface
if you don't care too much about a brand
new product well right now is the best
time to go out and buy a surface laptop
2 because they're getting slashed across
the world and their prices are dropping
rapidly just so that everybody can clear
their stock and get ready for all these
new surface devices that's always an
awesome indicator if you're out and
about looking at new laptops if their
prices are getting slashed heavily and
they never go on sale it means a new
surface product or a new laptop product
is coming out for their brand so there
are a couple of things that have been
almost confirmed in the room asphere and
a couple of things that have been thrown
out left right and center that seem a
little bit wacky but also seem like
Microsoft will do them so one of the
main things that I'm actually quite
happy that they're doing is they're
removing the proprietary charger so
there's no more magnetic lock on any
surface 3 product we're looking at using
only USB C ports on the side so right
now what my sources are telling me and
what other people have rumored basically
so far is the fact that we're going to
see two USB sea ports on one side and
one USB a port on the other so that way
you're always ready for the old
technology
and the new technology with this device
even though we're looking at seeing to
us they see ports on the one side and
one USB a port on the other the rumors
are that there will be no Thunderbolt
compatibility on this device so if
you're looking for something with
Thunderbolt compatibility you're
probably going to end up still sticking
with a macbook for the time being
something which is really fascinating is
the fact that Microsoft is rumored to be
coming out with two different models for
the Microsoft Surface 3 they're planning
on coming with an everyday consumer
model and also a business model so there
are two main differences here between
the consumer and the business model the
business model is predicted to come
without the Alcantara keyboard so all of
you guys have been asking me questions
in my comments below how's your surface
- held up over the years with the
Alcantara keyboard well the key ball has
been great but I know a lot of you guys
are a little bit wary about that product
there I'm sure you guys would be happy
to know that it's rumored the Microsoft
will be removing that Alcantara keyboard
and keeping it as a complete aluminium
body from top to-- inside and out now
the second rumor about the business
model I'm a little bit skeptical about
because well it is an aluminium for
unibody design steel but they are
rumored to be able to remove the SSD
replace it upgrade it and things like
that usually for all Microsoft products
especially the surface line there is no
way that you can open up one of these
products without completely destroying
it so it will be a very big surprise to
me if it does come out with an
additional SSD drive that you can pull
in pull out upgrade and do all sorts of
things with it now if you've seen the
ads for this release you've probably
already seen the fact that it's going to
come out in a rose gold color so so far
we've seen about four different colors
we've seen the black we've seen the gray
the cobalt and the Burgundy and
hopefully the rumours will hopefully be
true and we'll be getting a full unibody
aluminium design with no Alcantara
keyboard in a nice rose gold sleek
design now there is rose gold models
that you can purchase to the laptop too
but you cannot purchase them in
Australia and currently you cannot
purchase them in the US either so it
will be pretty nice to be a
have this extra option it's actually a
little bit of variety when it comes to
the surface laptops right now the key
thing behind this launch is looking to
be hardware and AI they're looking to
upgrade katana as much as possible and
they're looking to upgrade the hardware
inside the surface laptop 3 as much as
possible now there is a small chance
because this is going to be announced on
the 2nd of October that they're going to
be using Intel's latest ice Lake chip
now if Microsoft doesn't go ahead with
that upgrade or if they haven't had
enough time to implement Intel's latest
chip well chances are they're going to
be using in the ice whiskey chip which
is only one step up from the current KB
chip which is inside the surface 2 so if
they do upgrade it to only the ice
whiskey well realistically the power
input and the performance that you're
going to get from this chip versus the
KB chip isn't going to be dramatic
enough to warrant you operating from a2
to a3 but if they do come out with this
ice Lake chip then definitely it's going
to be able to warrant that upgrade for
all you guys out there with a surface 2
already now there are a couple
ridiculous rumors circulating the
Internet some of them may potentially be
true for a different surface device or
different Microsoft device but I
personally don't see it being
implemented in the surface laptop 3 now
one of the key specs that I keep seeing
pop up on Twitter and different forums
is the dual screen compatibility like
they have on the newest seuss duo Pro
now it'd be really cool to see something
like a dual screen come out on the
surface laptop 3 but that really isn't
the target demographic for this product
I personally see the dual screen new
Microsoft product coming in a completely
different package a completely different
shell but I don't see it coming in the
laptop 3 something that has a little bit
more potential and something that would
be really nice to see in a laptop
actually even though we haven't really
caught on to it with our mobile phones
is wireless charging there are a few
rumors circulating at the moment that
wireless charging will be Microsoft
go-to feature and part of their whole
new hardware revamp that they
be pushing so hard on October 2nd but as
for the information we've genuinely been
given from Microsoft we actually haven't
been given that much info we've received
a launch day graphic that if you look at
it closely there isn't really too much
to see
or you can potentially get out of it is
a 1 and a 0 which makes a 10th month and
a 0 and a 2 which makes the second day
of October so the faint outline of the
Microsoft logo could potentially be
nothing more than just the date of the
launch or well like the DJI launches and
everybody that's a little bit clever
with their marketing there may be
something that we're missing inside this
logo but personally I haven't been able
to see it and lots of you guys out there
haven't been able to pick it either and
that's all I have for you guys today
about the Microsoft Surface laptop 3 I
will come back to you again on the 2nd
of August when we have some more
information when they drop all this new
product hopefully different devices and
new Microsoft Surface laptops as always
guys smash that subscribe button
20-19 style and I'll see you next Monday